yay hi nice um it is now right now and I
just went to my dog and I got back to my
apartment and I should be getting ready
for another audition that I have this
afternoon but no I'm gonna have a male
because male makes me so happy and so
excited and this is the better way to
prep for Manish applause have coffee
with whipped cream which hey I really
like that whipped cream Epis up my
stomach but I don't care I'm going to
force myself to get through it because
that's what you do for things that you
love right
okay that's open mail okay this is a
pretty envelope look at know your
address isn't on here so I can show it
post Canada okay so I'm tired it's
because I'm tired
whoa ah no cards happiness what Q
happiness tumblr calm whoo q happiness Q
happiness that's America QB oh and then
you sent one oh no wait Christmas
dumb-dumb hope I go and then you did
this so people would see Oh Q happiness
no matter what don't give up on hope
wake up every day and go out with the
intention of making the world a better
place on the gush one thing's for sure
you don't have to worry change is a door
that can only be open from the inside go
as big as you can go reach high don't
let anyone tell you know oh did it looks
like you wrote ho don't let anyone tell
you oh that would be funny
and this one's laminated which must mean
it's the most important one lemonade is
so cool it's like preserving something
forever thank you so much
q happiness tumbler calm that was really
made me feel really good and that's
actually a good way to get ready for
this position by just telling myself I
can do it ooh this one's from Eric
O'Brien from Reston Virginia just to
make this more difficult you put to hunt
masking tape avenge hi
own masking tape who goes up to the
store buys masking tape unless you're a
teacher I don't know did you answer that
out loud for me so I can't hear it
though what is this a letter Allah oh
you have next and reading for a boy and
then you put braces this is my youtube
Eric vlogs now oh cool and then you put
o the bracelets you made both of them
holy crap look how cool is it's like 3d
ah we had 3d glasses how cool would this
be these are so neat and then what this
is oh my god it says Daily Grace it's a
backwards just Daily Grace holy crap I
love homemade bracelets we used to make
these when we were younger and then you
put a wish you tied around our ankle and
then when eventually it falls off after
like weeks or months or days that's when
your wish was supposed to come true and
it never really happened cuz you would
forget about what your wish was by the
time they fell off but it was always so
fun and these are amazing thank you so
much Eric and I'll read this letter
later I promise it's just not
entertaining to read a letter to
yourself on a video right guys right huh
you know okay this one is from Boston
University what is going on
uh-oh someone works at Boston University
sending me this sign up Boston
University Pickering educational
resource library g-dub's AKA grace
helbig dailygrace I'm reading this
letter at work with my favorite pen
because I'm bored
your handwriting isn't as good as the
other people's 10 writings but that's
okay I really appreciate um this Boston
University it's in Canada I think you're
lying but who knows oh you said I'm a
role model that's so cool from Jenny
Chang oh thank you so much this is
really sweet
thanks for writing this wall at work huh
the funny that people would work on
these jobs United State
and then half the tech are not actually
doing work during your job pulling crap
is a lot on the back side oh my god
there's all these PPS is a PSP I'll
never not be a five-year-old boy this
will be read later
Thank You Hannah Cohen of Deerfield
Illinois
do you have deer in that know what I'm
tired because I'm tired
Oh pink oh no pink oh and I can already
see there's some sort of drawing on here
holy crap you guys are amazing artists
look at this
look it that's my face ready like
Tennessee that's me oh my gosh that's
amazing thank you so much I need your
flowers that's so so great when you say
you're obsessed with my videos that's
awesome it's better than being obsessed
with heroin tell your mom she's welcome
PS it would have sent you some funfetti
brownies but they wouldn't vinyasa it's
probably for the best
thank you no this is so cool you're very
amazing artist I hope that you do art um
in your everyday life you know Dylan
Brown whoa cool handwriting already whoa
I like your style commentary comes off
you made a very personalized envelope
thank you for that that's so cool open
and open a conference call with someone
in like 20 minutes I'm trying to get
this through quickly oh my god you guys
are amazing artists look at that that's
me this is amazing
Wow Thank You Dylan Brown you're 18
years old from okay so but I'll catch up
something I don't know
and despite your penmanship you're a boy
like you're a boy and you did this this
is pretty fantastic
oh my gosh I love this
and you drew you Benes these are
fantastic thank you so much Dylan Brown
this is really beautiful
I'm gonna read the whole thing later
that is the sweetest candy letter okay
what's next
Thomas d-day coast from New York New
York oh my gosh we live so close to each
other are you watching me open this
right now I'm hope not hey grace how are
you I'm a huge fan just ordered a what's
up [ __ ] shirt huh
thank you for monitoring that that's
really very kind of you hope to see you
at the pit soon oh thank you so much and
look this little cuckoo I'm feeling you
Oh Pete isn't that so cute thank you
thank you so much Tom frogging Tom how
do you like New York yeah I know it
sucks right it's like really spot but
also like really dirty whoa postcards
look all these postcards oh wait this
was backwards Wow Wow okay
holy crap postcards um hi grace I hope
you like my penmanship I do
where's this postcard from hey Stuart
ports mouth Portsmouth Portsmouth ports
mouth you gonna put some port wine in my
mouth huh you are one of my favorite
comedians from Holly or Molly Molly or
Holly it looks like it could be an M or
an H thank you so much this is an
awesome postcard sure yeah I'm I
repurposed that so that someone else who
knows hi grace thank you for your videos
I wish you got this postcard for another
youtuber and subscribe too but then I
got oh did you well fine Ashley thank
you for the Liberty Bell that was meant
for another youtuber just kidding thank
you that's very sweet
I'll take seconds I don't have a
preference hi grace from officially
somewhat oh I'm officially what
something of my friends Oh got my
friends hooked on your YouTube videos
their Facebook are covered with gray
stuff now yay be nice it's America can
you see it can you see it like that
that somebody America very cool and this
is from Zoe
I think Zoe and wait
I'm ready I'll be this later thank you
so much thank you this is adorable
will you oh this is also so easy
somebody who I met before
thank you this is China wow this is what
China looks like guys so if you didn't
know now you know oh okay I'll read this
later I'm gonna cut up writing in my
head in front of a video but were you
there Thank You Zoey that's so nice you
said that you made Boccaccio's because
dad's birthday that's awesome
did you like it I hope so this is whoa
something just fell out I made this and
it's a bracelet oh cool look they said I
made this who is this from Bailey Warren
again wait didn't I just have Bailey
worn maybe not what I don't know I'm
getting confused oh yes I remember you
remember your handwriting I'm judging
you by your stationery yeah cuz you go
Winnie the Pooh all over this crap thank
you so much Bailey yeah I opened your
letter last time I remember your
penmanship is so incredible you go to
Clemson University I don't know what
that is or where that place is but it
sounds like a made-up school but that's
okay so did my college thank you very
much for that note that's so nice of you
this is from Seth McLain thank you oh
it's a little thank-you card for all the
laughs your videos make me smile
everyday Seth oh just testing to see if
the snail things don't work sigh just
kidding keep entertaining the internet
would be deprived if you ever stopped
that's so nice
Thank You Seth I love the simplicity of
this it's very cool thank you thank you
thank you belittling me me me wait what
oh look the coast of us did to this the
post office is made up of savages it
really is who's this from Amanda fix
something Amanda with an F from Puerto
Rico holy crap holy crap oh I just
ripped your letter more
okay grace yes I'm a fan and I love your
videos I have to enjoy your blog and
your sense of humor but I have to say
that I do love your outfits oh thank you
you're a comedic genius Thank You Amanda
that's so so sweet this is what a cool
little letter a little something for
Puerto Rico oh thank you that's so so
nice this is sorry that the post-office
ripped up your envelope like the savages
that they are who's this from Alana
Ofsted ooh from New Zealand totally
where the crap have you seen Frodo
lately ha ha ha
learn to the Rings guys so whoa okay
booth would owe your penmanship is so
cool look it's also antique it's like
italicized
nice grace so I guess all of your fan
mail begins with what's up [ __ ] but
this isn't a letter to entertain you
this is a thank you oh oh my gosh is
this the nicest thing ever thank you for
making us all smile on your endless
entertainment oh thank you so much Ilana
this is really really meaningful to me
thank you this is very very sweet I hope
that you continue to watch this videos
and everything is fun and nice because
everything is fun and nice when you
think about it you saw my weight how do
you think about it if you say this is
fun then it's gonna be fun just let
things be fun okay please reply from I'm
the nameless person let's see
please don't be interact it's me by
Johnny and ember I think it's me as a as
a mermaid that's [ __ ] just kidding I
think she's sitting on a rock that's
adorable
we love your video so much please
mention this later on Daily Grace it may
be shout out to a deep under birthday if
it's not too much Jony member happy
birthday daddy puns for this picture
that's so sweet of you guys alright I
got a whole quick I got a little quick I
got a little quicker than the other yeah
oh here's a little guy Grace Albany
do not bend please Oh Royal Mail to
Prince William send me something finally
oh this is wrapped so tightly it's
wrapped in the world paper this open you
did such a good job wrapping this
eep-eep scissors come help me okay wake
up I don't wanna okay go there
helicopter obnoxious okay what's in here
oh my god I am excited concerned it's a
CD of what July what is it what is it
here's a letter miss discover your
videos on YouTube one of them mentioned
not really listening to music I'm being
in crowds
so I'm just I'm making you a mix CD
thank you oh my gosh that is awesome
you're a female from England and not a
sex pest I love that term sex pest
that's fantastic but what is your name
did you write your name you didn't put
your name down here this is from such an
honest and your beautiful handwriting so
beautiful what is this I have to listen
to this later oh there's another note in
here oh there's a ah ah you put a
playlist thank you so much for this
that's awesome I will listen to this
because my music is so terrible right
now on my ipod and I was just thinking
about how much I hated it I started to
spit ice back into my coffee
it wasn't gross so I didn't spit it's
just I have ice crap whatever okay let's
um look at the leaves got it's let's
open these oh wait there's no motor in
here oh wow okay holy crap look they're
dancing yeah who is this from grace I
found this card while I was cleaning my
room and watching one of your male blogs
figure was a sign that's awesome
Thank You Hilary that's so cool dance
dance dance dance dance dance accent
that Stan says this is kind of how I
didn't just totally like a hologram
Kelly Kaelyn Rodriguez pronounced Kaelyn
I did it right with you all right
just the cutest little leather
hi grace it's 3:30 know what brain there
you go
how do yo grace it is 5:35 a.m. here why
didn't you go to sleep and I just
finished a project for my class so then
I go sleep cuz it's late right wrong I
watched grace all these new video is
about a fan now Wow well thank you so
much killer
Caitlyn Marie for this letter that's so
sweet how did you join your project was
it okay did you get good scores good all
right this is from South Gate Drive
State College Pennsylvania why did I
stay the address I don't know whoa Chloe
well well well we will oh you gave me
blank cards and envelopes and a magnet
that's a little frog or a little crane
or something whoa work on me and it's a
magnet how cool is that okay what is
this dear grace my friends and I love
you and your videos our days are just
not complete until we've watched you the
note cards are me and magnet I've sent
our products handmade of course in my
online store Zen color stop Big Cartel
calm hope you like them wow these are
cool look at these little cars they have
China on them all China look it's all
China oh if you guys like these cards go
to Zen where is it
Zen colors up Big Cartel dot-com so cute
thank you so much it's so nice of you to
have me promote your store on my now
look just kidding thank you for those
things that's really really sweet okay
this is from Kristin off ler from
Warwick Rhode Island
Oh Lord I didn't such a tiny little
state and they know people live there
well uh I sent you this letter but the
post doc sent it back
oh no not enough postage so here's a
letter in a letter I made you this
bracelet look at this oh my gosh I'm
gonna have so much jewelry to be wearing
like a person that wears oh no what is
this you sent me a spoon with Oprah's
face on it that is really wonderful oh
my goodness what is there an explanation
I put no explanation for that I just
wanted to say thank you for your humor
in your videos they really make my day
every single morning I want silly girls
before I brush my teeth even oh yay by
the way I made you Oprah spoon puppet
made it by hand
thank you this is wonderful you gonna
thank you and you know thank you my show
is over uh thank you so much that's so
sweet of you
okay what else we have Rachel Wilson
whoa a laminated letter holy crap I am
your biggest fan
Wow
oh you do I guess this is us hanging out
look there's ice this is how we hang out
this is how we hang out thank you so
much Rachel I'll say this is awesome oh
man that's so cool thank you but you
guys are like really amazing artists and
it's just really amazing Kathleen may
Lamas from Mount Vernon New York I know
that place how do you like it there
scissors help me
oh yeah yeah hello
what pocket posh crosswords you sent me
a little book of crossword puzzles this
is great because I have run out of
things to do on the subway and the
reading is just for the birds
am i right an envelope in an envelope oh
let's see
oh my gosh it's a cat look at that cat
being a [ __ ]
look at it hey grace firstly want to say
and then I love your channel oh just
some apple set tumbler calm very cool
huh thank you so much for the crosswords
I will play this and also it has a
really good texture so if I'm ever on
ecstasy I'm just gonna be doing this
cool thank you so much it's so nice of
you and then finally our last one is
Snoopy thanks from Hayley Smith I think
I've met you Hayley unite up like 20,000
pictures together right oh all right
Jimmy stop resisting oh so good ah that
is so cool
Thank You Hayley and you just look at
that well holy crap that is pretty
amazing
Hayley loves praise oh I love you puts
honestly yeah yeah oh my gosh she wrote
so much you probably don't remember me
but I'm one of the girls who made you
Oreo stuff chocolate to cruise yeah this
girl made me Oreo stuffed chocolate chip
cookies and brought them to the people's
Improv Theater and they were delicious
thank you so much for them huh also many
close to sexual Silly Bandz oh no where
that puts them there somewhere around
here I think they spun on the floor I'll
find them they're being so sexy I can't
even find them I'll find them in second
my stuff's all over the place
Wow thank you so much Haley six one six
sexy Friday turtleneck on also yeah she
started a sexy Friday at tumblr calm so
if you want check it out feel free to
check it out this is so cool well thank
you guys so much for all your mail today
I hope that um oh okay
now I need to get all the rest of my day
thank you guys so so much I hope that
you're having a great great day I
remember fun is fun and everything is
fun so just say this is fun this is fun
bye